ce que je peux vous dire c'est qu'en
fait le 21 avril dernier en pleine nuit
enfin donc le 22 au matin
s'accompagne soi-disant à appeler
ma mère pour demander en disant
rendez-le-moi rendez-vous le mois alors
vous vous êtes qui par rapport à Harry
juste pour les télescope cousine sa
cousine exactement
où j'avais interdiction de le voir
puisque c'est comme une perverse
narcissique vous savez ça mais elle lui
a fait croire la lune de miel elle l'a
mis sous emprise voilà elle a écarté de
nous tous donc forcément c'est comme si
vous deux jour au lendemain vous allez
voir quelqu'un visiter quelqu'un dans un
hôpital et que cette personne disparaît
donc vous comprenez pas vous essayez de
le joindre vous il avait signé une
décharge et en fait elle l'avait drogué
pour cela donc en fait c'est une vraie
c'est un vrai travail de perversion de
longue haleine elle
qui se sont passés pendant ces 10 ans il
prenait même plus de métadonnes il
prenait plus rien du jour au lendemain
cette femme lui apporte des choses à
l'hôpital en fait cette femme elle vient
chercher son traitement de substitution
elle l'appelle Alain alors qu'il
s'appelle Harry d'ailleurs c'est ce que
je vous ai déjà dit à 4 ans et personne
ne m'a cru en fait les photos vous
saviez qu'il allait avoir un drame
évidemment
sinon enfin on a tout fait bien alors
par contre ce que je ne comprends pas
c'est pourquoi il y a pas de suivi mais
c'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui est mis
pllégique on le laisse pas à quelqu'un
sans assistance sans
pourquoi ce elle a coupé comme une
perverse elle a tout coupé autour elle
l'a mis dans dans sa bulle elle le
droguait donc il avait gagné amoureuse
pour faire le espèce d'ADN là dont je
vous avais dit à 4 ans que nous on
n'était pas du tout de c'est à dire pour
prouver que c'est bien le fils à l'un de
l'autre elle elle voulait l'argent en
fait c'est comme un guet-apens c'est à
dire quelqu'un a dû lui dire tiens
regarde là-bas il y a Alain alors que
c'était Harry et c'est parti ah bon
c'est le fils de ah mais alors attends
on va pouvoir Harry n'a jamais pensé à
faire une drôle d'ADN regardons sous
emprise elle a imaginé que un jour elle
pourra avoir gain de cause
n'a pas été élevé comme ça Marina n'a
pas été élevée en étant le fils de Harry
a été élevé en tant que lui-même et il
savait très bien que que de toute façon
à ce niveau-là il n'aurait jamais rien
de son père du mois j'entends
la justice française avait tranchée en
disant monsieur Delon résidence nous ne
sommes pas compétents il y aura pas de
recherche d'ADN donc depuis quelques
années on savait qu'aucune recherche ne
serait menée à ce niveau-là on peut le
regretter mais pourquoi selon vous
continuez tel à le maintenir sous
emprise puisque la justice avait dit
nous ne chercherons pas la paternité
éventuelle bah parce que parce qu'elle
était persuadée qu'en fait elle
arriverait à avoir l'héritage Alain
Delon tout simplement une part d'humain
elle pensait réellement que Harry
aller faire jusqu'au bout l'ADN aller
faire enfin que ça allait fonctionner
pour que il reste en vie et aller au
bout de ce que de cette hypothèse là
parce que là pour quel intérêt elle a le
laisser se dégrader de la sorte elle a
vu quand elle a vu que
que en fait sa proie n'allait plus être
sa propre vous savez comment fonctionne
un pervers narcissique il vous met sous
l'une de miel il vous fait espérer des
choses il vous manipule ensuite il
écarte tout le monde autour quand il a
écarté tout le monde autour il vous
détruit et là il vous dit comme elle
faisait la laisser tout seul vous avez
agi du coup pour Marie justement il y a
quelques semaines tu as même fait venir
Marie les policiers chez lui parce que
tu sentais qu'il y avait quelque chose
qui allait pas il ne sent pas venu ah
ouais bah non
c'est ma mère qui leur a dit donc ma
mère leur a demandé alors il y a aussi
un problème avec la police que quand
vous appelez un commissariat en fait
c'est de région en région donc si vous
mettez encore vous pouvez pas voir Paris
si je veux dire c'est quand même un peu
mal fait l'histoire donc jouer en Joseph
on pouvait pas appeler Paris 15e je
crois donc c'est le commissariat de
Versailles qui a appelé le 15e
finalement ma mère aujourd'hui
pour nous dire rendez le moi ça veut
bien dire quoi ça veut bien dire nous on
s'est dit ça y est nous on l'a tué
rendez-le moi ça veut dire quoi
je ne pouvais pas et soit elle l'a tué
il est au sol devant elle ce qui est le
cas si le cadavre est dégradé depuis et
en fait ce qui m'énerve le plus c'est
que la police nous a dit il n'y a pas de
mal en péril c'est en gros c'est vous
qui vous faites des films donc lâchez
l'affaire il va très bien nous l'avons
vu en fait ils ne l'ont pas vu moi j'ai
hâte de savoir la date réelle de sa mort
parce que ça voudrait dire que la police
n'a pas fait son travail
comment vous expliquer ça sérieusement
c'est fou oui mais vous n'avez pas
autorité sur la personne d'Harry c'est
très bien nous en occuper mais vous
n'avez pas d'autorité exactement ce que
tout le monde me répondent donc en fait
je dis pas ça mais vous pouvez pas à mon
avis là où on en est accusé la police de
n'avoir pas agi mais moi ce que je pense
alors je vais vous donner ma version et
c'est que la mienne donc c'est sûr que
c'est absolument pas objectif dans le
fond c'est que comme si vous lisez la
presse comme tous les soirs apparemment
il venait enfin pas peut-être pas tous
les soirs entre guillemets souvent les
voir elle ne laisse jamais rentrer les
gens n'importe qui même le curateur la
kiné n'avait pas le droit il se pète le
fémur il y a un an la kiné n'a pas le
droit de le voir donc à rien n'a pas eu
de
de rééducation comment ça se fait que
personne dise si tout le monde avait
signalé la kiné le curateur tout le
monde au bout d'un moment il serait dit
oh là là il y a quand même vachement de
dossier sur Harry Boulogne il faut
peut-être se bouger un petit peu donc
pourquoi je dis que la police n'est pas
passée parce que on peut pas on peut pas
nous dire qu'ils l'ont vu que tout va
bien alors moi je pense que ils se sont
dit ah c'est encore les deux cassos de
toxico-capelle oh laisse tomber on va
leur dire que tout va bien il y avait
pas de voiture le 22 pour y aller donc
le 23 ils ont été la police pour moi et
pas ils sont pas responsables
j'ai pas dit que la police était
responsable j'ai dit que pour le moment
il y a un point d'interrogation la
police nous a dit le 23 tout va bien il
n'y a pas de mal en péril en attendant
attendant de savoir ce que va donner
l'autopsie si l'autopsidique ça dure
depuis perpète et puis un mois entre oui
un mois ce qui est fou c'est que ce sont
les
Alain Delon n'a pas reconnu Harry mais
ce sont les
qui vont récupérer Harry et l'élever
c'est fou ça non mais alors ça c'est
autre chose c'est en fait c'est parce
que
ma grand-mère en fait ce qui se passe
c'est qu'un jour il y a Nico qui appelle
ma grand-mère à Bourg-la-Reine en lui
disant ça va mal je n'arrive pas à
m'occuper d'Harry donc ma grand-mère dit
mais c'est qui arrive c'est qui cet
enfant donc elle prend un avion pour New
York elle part à New York elle voit
Harry elle découvre quoi un bébé
magnifique assis sur un piano qui boit
des coupes de champagne quand elle
demande à Nico de lui changer la couche
elle se rend compte de quoi ma
grand-mère et la couche est pleine de
drogues elle cachait sa drogue dans la
couche de Harry donc qu'est-ce qu'elle
fait c'est une maman vous êtes quand
même maman tous tout cela
mais qu'est-ce que vous faites dans ces
cas-là qu'est-ce que vous faites
à Paris l'adoption comment on adopte
Harry si on adopte Harry et dites
adoptary il faut l'accord d'Alain il
faut l'accord des deux enfants pour
adopter on peut pas adopter comme ça
donc là ma grand-mère a commencé à faire
du la sérénade à mon grand-père on lui
suppliant mon grand-père a évidemment
accepté donc ma mère s'est mouillée elle
a été obligée de signer et son frère lui
a dit bah alors je te parlerai plus
jamais parce qu'en fait il ne voulait
pas on peut pas forcer quelqu'un
voilà je peux pas défendre mon oncle
c'est juste que ce qui ne dépend pas de
nom on peut pas le changer en fait moi
j'avais une question c'est lorsque votre
grand-mère a récupéré ce petit bébé
justement est-ce qu'elle l'a adopté en
tant que son petit-fils dans sa tête ou
est-ce qu'elle adoptait dans le doute
c'était le fils de son fils et et ça se
ressent
que c'était son petit Vinci est-ce
qu'elle en a voulu à son fils de pas le
reconnaître ou est-ce que c'était le
sujet de leur discorde où c'était plus
un autre sujet le fait qu'il se soit pas
parlé pendant 17 ans c'est surtout ça de
pas avoir reconnu son fils
aussi ils se sont pas parlés pendant 17
ans c'est parce que
après je sais pas au début de la
carrière de mon oncle apparemment
c'était en même temps que James Dean il
fallait se créer un gros problème un peu
tu vois qui fasse gonfler et du coup
enfin ça c'est le je vous répète ce que
ma grand-mère m'a dit
et en fait donc il fallait accentuer un
peu tu sois les traumatismes de
l'enfance ou les donc on a en
l'occurrence c'était le côté nourrice ou
autre enfin oui comme on appelle ça oui
nourrice et du coup
au départ ça a été ça donc ma grand-mère
a
eu très mal dans son cas après il y a eu
d'autres choses par exemple alain a cru
que c'était ma grand-mère qui avait
signé le papier pour Indochine alors que
c'était Alain Fabien c'était Fabien
Delon pardon chez moi
c'est quoi le bail
quand il a fait un Indochine c'était il
fallait à l'époque signer des papiers
les parents devaient signer des papiers
c'est mon père
est rentré dans le groupe Indochine bon
bref réagis à sa mort
arrive non je crois pas juste les
changements de texte dans les articles
de presse fallait pas dire l'enfant
légitime mais fallait dire celui qui se
faisait passer d'ailleurs je voudrais
revenir là-dessus
Harry n'a jamais ne s'est jamais
considéré comme le fils d'Alain jamais
la seule chose qui se passait c'est que
tout public qui venait à lui vous êtes
le fils de donc en fait c'était que la
ressemblance mais lui ne s'est jamais il
n'a jamais été arrogant c'est absolument
quelqu'un de simple mais il a quand même
entamé une procédure de reconnaissance à
paternité donc c'est qu'il avait quand
même envie
de cette Alain Delon a des enfants
légitimes est-ce que ces enfants
[Musique]
bah rien rien de toute façon il était
émiplégique d'accord donc les cures la
drogue c'est terrible il a dépression
j'imagine aussi la dépression forcément
et en fait pourquoi il retourne à chaque
fois c'est parce que comme c'est sa
maman qui l'a drogué la première fois en
fait si tu veux c'est le lien maternel
chaque femme qui vient qui lui donne de
l'amour et qui en plus lui propose genre
de choses paf c'est foutu alors là vous
savez quand même il a rencontré une fois
Alain Delon il a rencontré en vrai à
côté du métro facile si vous voulez je
peux vous dire il lui a dit la main sur
l'épaule ça c'est bien c'est bien
là
tu es mon pote mais je veux te dire un
truc tu n'as pas mes yeux tu n'as pas
mes cheveux tu n'es pas mon fils tu le
sauras jamais mon fils alors
un petit quelque chose il y a un petit
quelque chose c'est pas ouf mais il y a
un petit quelque chose non non ça il se
ressemble de ouf là
on a le droit aussi de pas vouloir
reconnaître un enfant qu'on a pas désiré
et avec une personne qu'on a vu une
seule fois dans sa vie c'est des
manières de lui dire mais un peu de cœur
quand même alors c'est vrai que il y a
une voisine de l'immeuble qui dévoile
des clans
parce que ça compagne a été placé en
garde à vue s'accompagne la compagnie
pourquoi pourquoi elle était mise en
examen pourquoi mais pour homicide
volontaire et non assistance à personne
en est je suppose ça vient de tomber
l'assistance à personne
motif parce qu'il soupçonne
effectivement que elle n'a pas fait tout
sans aller aussi loin que vous madame
qu'elle n'a pas fait tout pour le
maintenir en bonne santé ou pour appeler
les secours etc donc du coup ils mettent
en examen et tout de suite le parquet a
dit nous irons jusqu'au bout pour
connaître les causes exactes de la mort
donc il y aura une enquête des
expertises pour connaître la vérité sur
la fin tragique d'arrêt mais il y a une
voisine qui déclare avoir vu
traverser la cour il y a une semaine ce
qui étonne au regard de l'état de
décomposition du cadavre oui mais ça ça
paraît complètement
elle a vécu ça voudrait dire en tout cas
ça s'est passé le 21 dans la nuit et à
ce moment-là le rendait le mois prendre
la valeur et à ce moment-là nos appels
entre les hôpitaux et le commissariat
seulement comme elle laisse rentrer
jamais personne chez elle peut-être que
elle a dit à la police peut-être que la
police est passée qu'elle a dit non tout
va bien c'est encore une dispute comme
les autres gens voyez un petit cinéma et
et il dort en fait son truc c'est
toujours il dort si si vous appelez
qu'elle voulait pas vous le passer il
dort je vous repasserai pas donc en fait
elle a un don vous savez comme tout
pervers narcissique en fait afin de
travailler les gens et les manipuler
dans le sens et elle y arrivait donc
peut-être que la police est passée
d'accord je veux bien mais à ce
moment-là elle a peut-être pas ouvert la
porte mais la police le but c'était de
le prendre à part de lui parler de lui
demander vous voulez toujours rester là
ou non et là ils auraient peut-être vu
qu'il est il dormait pas mais qu'il
était déjà mort mais cette fin c'est
inhumain ce qui est arrivé ce qui s'est
passé en état de décomposition comme ça
mais c'est la folie et ça n'arrive pas
en quelques jours ce qui s'est passé
donc si vraiment on prouve que cette
dame est venue une semaine avant elle va
être très
emmerdé cette femme il y a plein de
couple alors plein de gens qui
comprennent pas qu'est-ce qui pourquoi
ils c'était un couple déjà extrêmement
on va dire toxique c'est-à-dire qu'ils
se disputait très souvent est-ce qu'on
dit les voisins voilà ça c'est vrai et
donc la question qui se pose et que vous
posez madame qui est claire c'est est-ce
que il est resté décédé des jours avant
sans qu'on sache qu'il était décédé
personne ne répondait c'est c'est il y a
quelque chose qui va pas non plus
c'était à lui d'appeler les forces de
l'ordre comme le suivi de dossier de ces
médecins de sepsi comment ça se fait
qu'on laisse partir quelqu'un comme ça
sans se soucier de ce qui se passe
et il prend plus de traitement et prend
plus de médicaments il y a quelque chose
qui va pas en fait mais c'est ça cette
fin tragique c'est une extrême solitude
et je veux dire mais évidemment
forcément cette femme était au courant
je rappelle tout de même que ce monsieur
Harry Boulogne il a deux enfants aussi
il a un garçon et une fille hein
je ne sais pas ils sont grands oui mais
il y en a un qui est né en 1999 et
l'autre et la fille blanche en 2006 oui
la non-assistance à personne dangereuse
ça peut aussi vouloir dire que il y a un
soupçon parce que quand même mis en
examen c'est qu'il y a des indices
graves et concordants faut le répéter
qu'il y a un soupçon sur le fait qu'elle
je veux mettre du conditionnel aurait
peut-être laissé partir Harry à un
moment ne s'en serait pas occupé et voir
aurait provoqué d'une certaine manière
son décès donc c'est la mise en examen
et est grave les les le faisceau est
grave est-ce que vous madame vous êtes
formel on ne peut pas le savoir mais il
faudra vraiment des expertises poussées
pour voir l'état du corps et c'est de la
butte confiance vous ne sortez pas
quelqu'un de l'hôpital vous ne le mettez
pas en
de cette façon là les gens de l'immeuble
disent qu'il était méchant mais Harry
n'était pas méchant c'est normal si vous
enfermez quelqu'un et que vous le
droguez forcément il devient méchant ça
devient un animal je suis désolé mais
juste une petite question pourquoi
pourquoi tu veux pas vous incriminer
quoi mais pourquoi vous vous avez pas
agi parce que vous avez l'air de tout
savoir et des semaines il y a plein de
gens quand même qui a un moment de se
dire le mec le mec il va passer à
essayer un moment il y a quand même des
moyens de de forcer un peu le dessin
quoi déjà je pars en courant ça me fait
peur donc vous l'aimez évidemment que
bah oui
tu te fous de ma gueule là en me disant
ça
fait 4 ans que je me bats à essayer de
le faire sortir de là-bas et toi tu me
dis en secondes
elle est avec un pervers narcissique et
tout il y a un moment on se dit le mec
il est dans un sale état il est proche
de la mort tous les jours je vais le
voir quoi je suis désolé elle a essayé
donc d'après toi personne tout le monde
a essayé
tout le monde a essayé
il faut elle veut pas nous laisser
rentrer dans l'appartement moi je
défonce importante
j'ai une question sur la dépendance à la
drogue alors vous avez expliqué que
selon vous il l'avait passé le cap des
cures qui ne prenait plus aucun produit
stupéfiant
toute sa vie Harry il a été sous
l'emprise de la drogue de sa mère on le
disait mais il faut savoir Cyril que à
un moment il a été placé en pension
pendant des années il ne savait pas il
était pas drogué
il ne savait pas que sa maman Nico le
cherchait pendant des années une quand
elle le retrouve il a 16 ans il se
drogue tous les deux il a raconté dans
un livre il partageait la même seringue
donc pendant des années mal à deux
minutes
des livres et la vérité il y a une
nuance
je vais vous répondre
il avait alors pourquoi 18 ans parce que
maintenant ça m'est revenu pourquoi 18
ans il a déjà fait une demande de
paternité parce qu'à chaque fois qu'il y
a une femme qui est une droguée qui est
ronde dans sa vie donc en l'occurrence
Nico elle voulait de l'argent la
dernière fois qu'il a vu à l'homme il
lui a donné 2000 enfin d'équivalent de
2000 euros aujourd'hui à son bureau
parce que Nico réclamait donc ça ça
devait être à 18 ans il a fait cette
demande mais Harry ne fait pas de
lui-même cette demande il s'en fout que
Alain soit son père il a son père pour
lui dans sa tête c'est Philippe Gaëlle
ma mère c'est sa mère et Philippe Garrel
a toujours joué le rôle du père il a pas
besoin d'Alain Delon pour elle de comme
papa c'est dès qu'une nana droguée
voulait de l'argent le statut la beauté
la gueule nanani c'était parti donc
c'est pas compliqué en fait au tribunal
quand même le fait qu'il veuillait être
le fils d'Alain Delon madame sabot vous
pouvez pas vous l'écarter
plus jeune je ne savais pas qu'il avait
demandé à être reconnu comme le fils de
toute sa vie son combat était d'être
reconnu comme le fils de Madame
l'influençaient pour avoir pour pas lui
il s'en foutait
évidemment
c'était comme mon frère et un moment et
depuis c'est quoi quand est-ce que vous
êtes plus vu depuis 4 ans
parce que elle l'a kidnappé non ah ouais
bah oui depuis 4 ans
de l'avoir à la même enlever le numéro
de téléphone
en cachette mais le problème c'est que
par exemple il m'a dit un jour oui
t'inquiète pas tu es pour rien mais en
fait je crois que vous savez pas ce que
c'est que d'être sous l'emprise d'une
pervers narcissique je crois que
personne ne comprend ses enfants qui
sont majeurs
ils ont perdu leur papa enfin aussi
[Musique]
Charles vivier avec lui pas mal de temps
mais apparemment depuis un an il est sur
Toulouse bon bref j'ai pas envie d'en
parler parce que ça c'est aussi autre
chose il y a eu pas mal de troubles à ce
niveau là c'est à dire que depuis
qu'elle est rentrée dans la vie d'Harry
Charles ensuite par exemple est tombé
dans des trafics comme son père à tel
point qu'ils sont venus chez moi me
perquisitionner en octobre 2019 parce
qu'il avait fait croire qu'ils vivaient
chez moi alors que la police a compris
que non c'était pour esquiver le
logement rue Cambronne si vous voyez ce
que je veux dire vous voyez tout est
toujours et après il a il a il est tombé
dans le RER il a perdu les doigts de la
main donc il a passé son voilà donc
cette femme n'a été qu'une d'une boule
de pue dans notre vie on a une
malédiction c'est une valeur c'est fou
mais vous dites parce que quand
comme si comme si tout était devenu
transparent et je l'ai perdu l'auraient
jamais abandonné la kiné ne l'aurait
jamais abandonné enfin j'ai c'est
incompréhensible au fond
j'aime faire l'avocat du diable madame
est-ce que c'est pas votre vision de
leur liaison qui le disait était toxique
très compliqué et ce qui est-ce qu'elle
ne vous a pas en fait empêché de
continuer à le voir mais peut-être que
lui était amoureux de cette femme votre
vision n'est peut-être pas la bonne
est-ce qu'on peut supposer ça ou pas non
Harry parce que vous dites pervers
narcissique qu'est-ce que ça c'est pas
votre jugement à vous aussi sûrement
mais après tout je m'en fous en fait il
y a aucun problème c'est le truc c'est
que ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est qu'à
partir du moment où moi j'étais en train
voilà ça c'est aride d'accord on est à
terme en ville on boit la CI mangue là
il y a une femme qui arrive voilà et qui
l'appelle Alain je la regarde j'ai dit
non j'ai pas voulu lui dire son prénom
je lui ai dit non madame il s'appelle
pas là ça suffit vous pouvez bave
blanche crotte de nez enfin Harry n'a
toujours été avec des mannequins ouais
c'était ça en fait Harry n'a toujours
été qu'avec des mannequins du jour au
lendemain je me retrouve avec un
merci en tout cas Marie d'avoir été avec
nous c'est vrai que cette histoire est
complètement folle merci Marie s'oublier
Boulogne merci d'avoir été là merci